the way I see it especially with like
with like way staff right yeah I I like
unfortunately in America they get paid
dog [ __ ] and it's all tips right yeah so
even if someone sucks absolutely sucks
I'll I'll still tip them I'll still give
them a fat tip yeah because I see it as
like it's literally what if they
disrespect you even disrespect your girl
no even it's just like it doesn't matter
no matter what because like bro the
person that's never happened so I don't
know but the person there is having a
way worse time at it overall than that
brief interaction that you have I want
it to be on his side this cheat I want
it to be on his side I'm white I tip no
matter what because it's in my culture
but he actually what's funny is as he's
gotten richer he tips worse and worse
it's a really it's a really interesting
phenomenon it's a really interesting
[Music]
are you being serious I dead ass heard
you say to somebody probably in this
room when you go to a nice restaurant
they know you tip 15 that's just what it
is no 20 is bare minimum
bare minimum but what if they disrespect
you 20 and I [ __ ] am upset about it
you know what if they disrespect me I
tip 20 but I do it on the customer copy
oh so they have to do it yourself yeah
sometimes you'll do the math wrong
that's it and they'll still get the same
amount of money but it won't be the
right sense yeah yeah why are you making
up these Shenanigans uh yeah because you
got defensive and you're projecting no
he doesn't tip he does
this guy's never took 20 in his entire
[ __ ] life
this [ __ ] is good
that's one thing that dramatically
changed in my life is like back in the
day leaving your friends that are pieces
of [ __ ]
yeah you're attacking my culture okay
whites have few things but tipping is
one of them and we [ __ ] bring it dude
now I'm getting pressure from the
[ __ ] Turks over here 20 is a little
low for somebody Rich if I yeah yeah I I
do more than that yeah we'll do it I'll
just take it off [ __ ] take it off
um it depends so like uh first of all 20
is definitely the minimum right no
matter what happens no I don't think you
deserve
20.00
stand on that ten toes down if you suck
you don't deserve 20. I I don't I I
don't like the Tipping culture that we
have regardless but if you're decent
even at least 20. for me for me it's not
based on performance like 20 is the uh
bare minimum because like I don't see it
as like a Performance Based composition
I literally see it crazy I see it as
like survival like this dude this dude
needs the money bottle waitress she
needs it she needs it she needs 20 I
just no matter what it is like one thing
I never wanted to do when I was younger
is like I never used to tip when you
like go to a Chipotle and they just ask
you and it's like well I'm picking up
the [ __ ] you know I'm picking up the
food here now right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah now they don't deserve it
right now definitely no it's not that
they deserve it it's just I was also
kind of broke you know what I mean but
now I I even tipped in like I just drop
a oh that's crazy now you're a little
over East what about ubereats always I
do the percentage now it's like I think
it's like 25 is the max that you have uh
in the in the immediate allocations it's
like 15 20 25 as well I give an amount I
give a straight amount yeah it just
depends it depends but usually it's like
if it's like
yeah five dollars oh now we back now
he's back I got that number from him
it's the same work to bring the one the
thing over it's one hit boom you're not
writing nothing down wait come on
you're not asking me how's everything
tasting tonight I give them that Ibraham
Lincoln bro if you don't ask me how's
everything tasting tonight that's it
that's it that's crazy oh that
disrespect waitresses like that I'm
gonna pay this yeah the waitress was
with me the entire night checking on me
water risking his life to get the food
to you yeah
get a drone it's literally words that
you're using their own [ __ ] car
they're paying for gas they're getting
parking tickets and [ __ ]
all right six dollars
you got some good points there no it's
so much worse like I I definitely I
definitely go uh max out you max out or
it depends on if it's like a big order I
think I should tip them more and
waitresses less okay what about uh
Host Club
dollars come on bro dollar I have been
like I don't think I've ever I don't
think I've been to a strip club since I
haven't been broke so I don't even know
like I just I have not been in a strip
club recently so I don't know what I
would do
I don't know what I'd do I mean I have
no problem with it like I love strippers
they're great but let's say that we're
all at the strip club yeah tonight maybe
tonight maybe all right we all have
wives so that probably won't happen but
in a hypothetical situation yeah right
are we making it oh yeah are we making
it rain yeah of course you got to do it
you have to you have to 100 percent
in the strip club you can't be like
respectfully giving like a hundred
dollar bill you know whatever it comes
[Laughter]
exactly yes yes
would you ever ball the dollars up and
that's disrespect that's disrespectful
is
each other
you're dividing conquer socialist Divine
yeah yeah but what he did I thought out
of everybody he was the most left oh did
didn't you think that that's what I did
[Laughter]
and Bun okay
on Instagram that's why I thought like
before anybody else
enemies pump fake
shooting threes fadeaways at the
strippers no it was coins okay you're a
crazy guy you're crazy make like one of
those like [ __ ] you know early 90s
comedy bully style like snowballs we put
like pebbles in it yeah exactly he's
like you balled up a dollar and put like
coins in it so it was waiting she didn't
duck I don't know like what do you want
me to say they were loving it though
they would go like this for the hoop it
was sick oh yeah yeah there was that one
strip club Claremont Lounge yep yeah oh
that's right the old ladies you don't
know about that oh in Atlanta oh the old
lady strip club no I'm getting it no why
the lady who crushes a beer can with her
titty sorry that was awesome smash
better pong ball out of the [ __ ] that's
no no elasticity left oh
you never know man if they've been if
they've been doing kegels they have like
a Competitive Edge over you know young
uh 20 year old strippers oh maybe yeah
yeah their pelvic floor is strong
shoving them it's like Yoshi eating a
watermelon yeah just spraying the whole
block oh my God yeah she's like oh you
thought I only had one ping pong ball
trying the third
she got the extendo clothes
yeah
dude we need to go back to Atlanta yeah
she's like oh you threw you threw coins
at me watch this
I got her way worse than she did I feel
like Abraham that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up but
shout out to strippers man like yeah you
know the real troops the real well yo on
the front lines yeah you know is there
anyone you won't tip that you
conventionally like would is there any
place where you're like ah these movers
I don't know
yeah you're crazy
there's plenty of places yeah that'll
tip my landlord why not but I mean I
don't even I have a house now anyway but
um when you pay your mortgage yeah no to
go coffee you get it to go coffee I
still tip I tip yeah I tip downstairs
yeah 20 I'm gonna ask them
and like when I do that some people like
you [ __ ] it up for everybody else I'm
gonna be honest the proposed with you
was against tipping and you didn't
believe me yeah probably now the truth
is coming out and I appreciate it
I'm being honest this whole time here's
the other reason though this guy just
conveniently forgets entire summations
that he gives these guys that's a good
point what if it's a fan you go there if
it's a fan I have to tip because but you
don't know but you don't know you do I
hate that [ __ ] yeah
off work dogs
he's not that's my whole point I love
tipping
come on come on anyway all right
no says he's a big Tipper
is tax evasion are we good with that or
no no no not at all you have to pay her
taxes I you have to pay your taxes I
it's such a [ __ ] complicated process
regardless which I wish it was easier
um but I mean most people that first of
all Every American does some form of tax
evasion which is crazy yes like there's
everybody all the way to the [ __ ]
yeah now you guys are all going to jail
okay I yeah I'm working with the 87 000
new IRS agents actually yeah undercover
yeah
um they're coming in right now but no I
mean taxes are important man it sucks
that it like goes to [ __ ] blowing up
brown kids and like uh Yemen with the
that's a great excuse for rich people to
not want to pay their taxes I I know
don't don't we all do that we're like oh
I don't want to give it to the
government so there's blood brown kids
the way I see it is like if they're
blowing up the right people we still
wouldn't want to pay yeah the they're
the way I see it is that it still is
like a fraction of it it's still going
to schools rows [ __ ] like that fraction
yeah fraction yeah I mean it's still
it's still those are incredibly
important fraction resources hey until
we smarter than China at math you should
lower my taxes
that's what I'm saying no American
[ __ ] likes that because like
especially since like the Reagan Era
everyone has been going on the star of
the Beast attitude where they're like
yeah [ __ ] the government and the Garment
[ __ ] sucks it's true there's no good
like we don't have any [ __ ] Health
Care Health Care bills are getting
higher and higher no matter what the
[ __ ] happens educate public education
sucks ass Democrats and [ __ ]
Republicans both want to take funds away
and create charter schools and [ __ ] that
are unaccountable agree and and really
[ __ ] awful in and of itself and
that's the mentality that genuinely
makes Americans go why the [ __ ] am I
paying tax I gotta tip the government
I'm not seeing anything from that yeah
which is why I love like you know the
the Trump uh the Trump bucks the
stimmies that was great that was for the
first time ever every American was like
wait a minute the government's like kind
of got my back a little bit yeah which
by the way the cnbce and like all the
[ __ ] you know Fox Business and
everybody else literally hated that I'm
still talking about it why well they're
like oh it's inflation you gave and poor
people money yeah you can't print that
much money without inflation happening
but most of the money wasn't printed for
the poor most of the money was printed
for the [ __ ] stock market yeah yeah
and also exactly PPP which you know
people abused the [ __ ] out of yeah now
they're getting locked up for no they're
not I mean a bunch of people yeah we
know a guy who went to jail for PPP it's
like Andrew's going to jail
no we yeah we do yeah I saw him on
Instagram recently taking his daughter
to
to uh jail
now sorry honey